ce smartphone a probablement la plus
grosse autonomie possible au monde vous
allez garder des jours des jours des
jours parce que vous avez une très
grosse batterie de 22000 millions par
heure là où aujourd'hui on estime avoir
de grosses batteries à 5000 milliampères
heure et bien là c'est plus de 4 fois
plus gros alors ça bloque on est à 540 g
chez franchement une brique que vous
mettez dans la poche et si vous venez de
mettre là regardez ça va vous éclatez le
jean mais pour autant le truc qui est
intéressant ici c'est que si vous avez
un sac à dos parce qu'il faut pas le
mettre dans votre poche vraiment le
mettre dans un sac c'est très lourd mais
si vous partez à la montagne et qu'il
vous faut une énorme autonomie et bien
là vous avez un truc qui va vraiment le
faire le truc à savoir c'est que lorsque
vous allez venir le charger et ça va
prendre des heures ça va prendre des
plombs mais au moins on vient anticiper
alors je trouve ça marrant c'est
d'autres gens qui fait ça qui est un
fabricant chinois le smartphone
s'appelle le Vmax c'est un monstre mais
bon puisque on peut le faire pourquoi
pas le faire d'ailleurs dites-moi si ça
vous intéresserait vous est-ce que vous
en avez l'utilité de partir pendant des
heures sans croiser une seule prise
électrique pour venir se recharger et
est-ce qu'un smartphone comme ça
pourrait vous tenter oui non quoi
comment bien évidemment vous marquez ça
dans les commentaires